not only Joe Rogan [__] with me
that's not true I don't think he does
that's not true why do you say that have
you guys connected yet no why don't you
come to an alien dinner
I'd love to come to an alien dinner it's
because he's capping about the test
[Music]
here's my thing if he was on GH we would
see it in the face
elaborate GH starts to Puff you up he
also doesn't have gyno you don't have
the guy now
like the little titties you know what
I'm saying you don't have them uh moms
or the pods
I mean you got just nipples just them
nipples yeah if you were on if you were
on the good stuff you'd have some titty
but you don't have the GH face
you know Barry Bond's got the circle
face once he started getting on the GH
et cetera
you're lean but you really want to do
Rogan huh what do you mean I would love
to do I want you to ask him
how have you guys not connected have
that's what I'm saying someone happy
left me unseen twice wait you guys
message each other you text it I
messaged to him I'm I'm in the [__]
dark depths of his DMS
um just just in the abyss because
Rogan's a bag
you know I don't think it is that's what
I'm saying I think there's something
going on
because I have stories that I'm saving
to tell Andre Roman I'm really excited
about
I mean it's crazy that you guys haven't
spoken yet since no we've been in person
and he was very nice he's the man I I
can tell I love him
but he don't love me
I don't buy this I don't subscribe I'm
mad that he's not giving us everything
oh wait you're saying you're saving
stories from us and you're giving it to
Rogan look I'll give you a story
tell us a story all right let me see I
have it in my notes a real one yeah we
need the good [__] or a fake one if it's
good if it's better to talk about on
Rogan yeah
uh nah nah these are very rogan-esque
stories what does that mean like the
real man's man story
you got more drama but I'm offended this
[__] piece of [__] with your hot pink
nips talking [__] about being people I
think we're gonna suck those in a second
yeah take your shirt off [__]
[Applause]
being canceled
special
no what happened to the [__] Chinese
[Music]
[Laughter]
do a bow one time bro
it was a good [__] dude oh yes oh [__]
yeah that's a big one what's happening
right now is that an open armor
it's a little boy
that's crazy what's happening right now
just got this
Prime energy is 17 heck no yeah yeah
what is it what is it
that's a 16x Prime energy that's 16. I'm
hitting the back of that
this has the same amount of calories I'm
about to put some more that's a 12 ounce
Red Bull bro right now this [__] says
zero grams of protein let me tell you
something yo that big of prime is the
same amount calories is one 12 ounce Red
Bull there's no way yeah it's a scale
model yeah we're better for you bro
wow
160 calories in the Prime energy this
big when are you guys going to do an F1
we thought about it crossed our across
our plate yeah why not uh I mean that's
cool yeah it's cool if you take out Red
Bull it's over there's some cool teams
out there
some cool teams out there yeah we got
some good stuff in our plate bro
but you're not gonna do that sorry so I
didn't mean to I didn't mean
I was trying to drink it right